make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so can we all just admit that like
Donnie Cates is absolutely killing it on
the venom series like this this is crazy
like here's the funny thing
venom has not been this interesting
since like agent venom venom has not
been this interesting to me in a long
long time this is one of the coolest
things okay we're over so I kind of
introduced like the maker into the whole
thing with venom and then like Eddie
Brock sort of went forward as like agent
venom to a degree this kind of focuses
on the back side of the story right it
really kind of focuses a lot on Eddie
and like his perception of himself right
in terms of like the role he plays and
so on and so forth but also kind of
introduces a pretty important character
what did what it does initially is it
kind of opens up with like Eddie's
introspection of like his own life and
basically saying that like he's a
screw-up all he ever hear all he's ever
done is like screw up and bring like
pain and anguish to other people and
with a previous story where oversight
kind of you know basically had him show
up to his dad's house and really kind of
brought in the idea that that Eddie's
dad was sort of a dick or there was at
least a problem with the two of them it
really kind of focuses more on that when
he goes back to visit his dad again and
the two of them hate each other
something I know also when you guys kind
of notice here is that Donnie Cates kind
of plants the early seeds of a kind of
victim mentality here when it comes to
the father of Eddie in the sense that
like his father immediately starts
screaming at him and Eddie kind of hours
away and that's not something that you'd
normally see right like when you think
of Eddie Brock is venom you think of him
as kind of like this imposing force
right like nothing scares Eddie Brock
but one of the things that that Cate has
been focusing on a lot when it came to
as to has been a run is like the
character of Eddie and it's like the one
thing nobody ever really seemed to do
and I think that's one of the reasons
why so many people love the story of
venom so far because the simian itself
is as much of a story as Eddie Brock is
and then with the two of them kind of
working together you of course get the
cohesive unit of the symbian but when
the father of Eddie basically lashes out
and goes to attack him the Venom
symbiote responds accordingly now I
remember as we as we were kind of it was
kind of speculated by the maker the
venom simian is almost in kind of like a
catatonic state or almost kinda like a
brain-dead state in the sense that like
its personality and all that kind of
stuff is gone but it reacts in like a
defensive way now of course this brings
in Dylan now Dylan's been here for a
little bit right like he should have an
issue number seven but it's basically
been like the younger brother of Eddie
is how it's been shown so far as it was
kind of a cool little thing because when
that happens the Venom's to be a kind of
subsides rebonds itself to Eddie and
then least this is a very important
thing because what this shows is that in
a lot of ways the venom stimulus India
still functions a core
to what it is that Eddie wants but were
you end up having Eddie basically making
his escape you know with the Venom
symbiote and kind of neo taking off and
then a couple days later
Dylan basically picks up with Eddie
having been beaten by Eddie's father and
so again a pretty personal stake that's
being invested in here in terms of like
how this is unfolding because the
response of Dylan is we have to kill our
Father but with regards to the
conversation that goes on between the
two of them it's kind of these these fun
little discussions that go on of course
Eddie Brock is really just kind of like
I'd rather be fighting that dragon God
thing they're like talking to this
little kid but it's kind of a cool
scenario because this kid kinda starts
asking questions like aren't you a good
guy now like where do you stand on
things kind of asking these these moral
compass questions and the funny thing
about that is that in a lot of ways it's
kind of the audience asking the question
to Eddie Brock right like where are you
at morally right now are you a good guy
you a bad guy are you still somewhere in
between where do you stand I'm the cool
thing about the way that Donnie Cates
writes this is that Eddie Brock's kind
of like I don't really know I mean I'm
trying to do good things but like I'm a
really crappy person and that's where
things really begin to get a little
hairy because when we talk about this
whole idea when when Donnie Cates
introduced this idea that Eddie Brock's
father essentially went bankrupt as
results like the hospital bills and all
those things that Eddie Brock went
through after getting into a car wreck
our assumption was that the little kid
running out in front of the car was
Eddie Brock and basically he was injured
and his dad blamed him because of all
the all the mounting medical bills and
everything and it just made his father
broke the reality is a lot darker there
what it basically happened was Eddie
Brock had gotten drunk with a bunch of
his friends and then went joyriding and
killed a kid in the process and so
because of Eddie Brock's negligence
because of his ineptitude what this
basically meant was that his father
literally came along and said you know
well the police were interrogating we
were like look you're a rich man you're
very influential we can probably find a
way to make this go away but your kid
has to plead not guilty where Eddie
Brock wanted to like where he wanted to
basically sacrifice he wanted to be like
I'm guilty of this I've committed this
crime I killed this kid I should be
punished for it his father wouldn't let
him and this is really really important
here because this is kind of Donnie
Cates building on the character of Eddie
he noticed a venom semi it really isn't
a huge part of this little segment it's
focusing exclusively on Eddie
and what does really hits out here is
that Eddie was a good guy who made a
terrible decision
and where he was willing to go through
and deal with the consequences of it he
was convinced not to when his father
beat him when his father forced him to
basically admit that he was innocent it
was literally like hey his father paid
off the judges his father paid off
lawyers and that's what
his dad broke but basically he blames
Eddie Brock for but it's kind of a crazy
thing because the father of Eddie blames
Eddie for something that his father
created right like he could have just
let his son go to jail but under the
surface of all this you know under under
the waters here is like a father who
wanted to keep his son out of jail he
would go to any lengths to make sure
that his son was not imprisoned but it
really kind of begs the question who's
actually the good guy here though the
father who wouldn't let his son go to
jail the father who would do anything to
make sure his son wouldn't have this
black mark on the rest of his life that
he wouldn't go to jail forever or the
young kid who committed that act and was
willing to deal with the consequences of
it who's really the good guy here there
is no such thing as like absolute right
and absolute wrong it's all based on on
how things unfold and the compass there
and that's kind of the the message that
Eddie gifts to Dylan right like I'm not
a good guy I've done terrible things I
killed a kid and then I lied about with
the fact that I was guilty just so I
could get off because my father
convinced me to but the other part of
this and then really the way this kind
of folds into the nature of Eddie and as
far as this venom Sabine is concerned is
that Eddie still kind of feeling the
after-effects of this right like there's
this kind of hallucination that goes on
as Eddie begins to converse and begins
to get closer to Dylan sisimiut kind of
kicks in and then like basically tricks
him into believing that he's seeing like
the symbiote god right now we don't
really know the motivation behind this
but Eddie begins to lash out and when he
does so he witnesses Dylan and believes
Dylan's the symbiote God and then starts
attacking Dylan fully for Dylan to
basically kind of reason with him and
say hey look you're hurting me you have
to stop and then Eddie kind of really
coming to and returning to his normal
self but it's a cool little thing here
because Eddie starts coughing basically
starts bleeding everywhere so on and so
forth he's taken to a hospital by Dylan
only for us to find out that what's
basically going on here is that what the
maker overseeing his treatment
presumably by doing some pretty shady
stuff to make it happen that Eddie
Brock's cancer has basically returned
now the cancer of Eddie Brock is kind of
an interesting thing because it's almost
kind of like what Donnie Cates was
trying to do before it was done by
Donnie Cates the idea was to kind of
write Eddie out as a character who
wasn't using the Venom symbiote because
he had cancer because he was kind of
like essentially dying now when Dan
Slott did that he kind of rolled it into
the story of like mr. negative like the
idea that like mr. negative was was on
one hand he was the good guy like
treating all these people who were ill
and on the other hand like a villain you
know but it was a cool little
circumstance in terms of how it took
place but the recovery of Eddie Brock
was kinda like a little mini story arc
unto itself where he was trying to
basically atone for his past misdeeds
and different things like that now again
his cancer was made
secured by mr. negative that was really
the end of that and then in turn like it
allowed him to kind of go forward is
trying to be a good guy but what happens
is that while he's recovering in this
hospital he starts to have these
illusions of this girl and now Ann is
the sister that Eddie Brock had or at
least as it's explained by it by Donnie
Cates this history had the died of
cancer and then like he goes into this
room where he basically has his Uncle
Dan who's dying of cancer did all these
different people are essentially dying
of cancer in his life and it's kind of
sort of forcing him to go through and
like relive these circumstances over and
over and over again now we don't really
know what the end result of this
intention is of like why he's seen these
things that was not explained right off
the bat instead again it kind of jumps
to the maker talking to Dylan basically
saying look I'm trying to find a way to
pull the Venom symbiote off of Eddie
Brock and so on and so forth and try to
find a way to cure him and you know
different things along those lines but
then suddenly an Eddie's dreams state he
ends up with the belt Howard now the
belltower that Eddie Brock was at again
is kind of a hallmark of his character
at least in the church anyway at the
bottom of the bell tower but the idea
behind here was like you know according
to how it's written here he was going
there to die like right like you know
Peter Parker cost him like his job he
cost him all that kind of stuff when he
exposed Eddie Brock is basically like a
fraud and then in turn Eddie was gonna
kill himself but that's at the exact
same time during whether spider-man when
Peter Parker basically cast the venom
sybian off of himself and then in turn
the venom Samiha basically took you know
bonded itself to Eddie but it's kind of
interesting because for those who
remember the old stories of venom you're
probably looking at this and saying like
but that's not how this played out
though and that's exactly what Eddie
begins to realize is that these are all
illusions these things are not the way
that they work and when he begins to ask
the Venom symbiote why this is happening
in what's going on here suddenly like
the beans begin to get spilled that what
we basically end up learning here is
that every instance where Eddie Brock
basically had cancer he never actually
had cancer instead the Venom symbiote
was afraid that he would leave and so
Eddie we're having some kind of sickness
would look at the Venom symbiote and say
it heals me I'm gonna go back to it
essentially the Venom symbiote never
wanted to be alone it's all a ruse to
keep Eddie coming back and that's what
Eddie realizes that essentially the
venom Simmi has been treating him all
this time all these years it's been
manipulating him in order to make sure
that Eddie stays with it and what this
does is it takes decades of Em's venom
history and turns it on his head but
it's a cool little thing because when
Eddie begins to realize there's a bit of
semi it says like the reason why we've
done we've done is because we knew if
you realize the truth of who
Dylan was you would leave us and guess
when it dawns on Eddie Brock that Dylan
is not his brother that Dylan is his son
now what this does is it jumps back to
the amazing spider-man 375 an amazing
spider-man number 19 I think it was and
basically goes with like a woman I'm a
woman by the name of an I care what her
last name is but basically and was like
Chee venom right like the idea was that
doctor in the you know in the early
1990s back in 93 that Marvel wanted to
kind of introduce like more symbiotes
right because like venom was hugely
popular when he first popped up and was
a chick who is basically like the the
wife of Eddie at the time she got into a
conflict she basically sustained
injuries that would have killed her and
then any kind of split off a portion of
his simia which bonded to her healed her
and then she went forward achieving him
for a time and then in turn like he
ended up you know she ended up casting
the symbiote off and he got it back but
during that time when the simian left
her she ended up pregnant and so for the
most part like we didn't really know
what happened during that era
instead she ended up like dying you know
I think an initiative were 19 of her I
want to see it was amazing spider-man
number 19 volume 2 number 19 I'm not
gonna swear to that but basically like
the shoe is written out of the story and
so what this does is kind of come in and
like bookend of the whole thing and
basically say that like Ann went running
to the father of Eddie Brock and then
basically said like you're the only real
family that's there you have to raise
this kid I'll come back when I'm of
sound mind and of course like she never
did she threw herself off a building and
died it's a cool little thing here
because what this means is that with
Eddie going forward and realizing what's
happening the Venom symbiote literally
responds when you have like the father
of Eddie riding with Dylan and then in
turn like essentially going to like
attack him you know because he was
mouthing off and the venoms to me is
kind of like hey look what we're gonna
do is we're gonna push you to sleep and
then you're gonna wake up somewhere else
and that's what that's what is up
happening when the father of Eddie wakes
up he's basically in the same cell where
he forced Eddie to admit that he was
innocent for city to say like you're
innocent you're not gonna go to jail for
your crimes that kind of good stuff and
so what happens is like Eddie starts
addressing his father now this is very
important because up to this point Eddie
had basically always chalked up like the
failures of his life to the abusive
nature of his father and it was one of
those things where Kate kind of hinted
the idea that like Eddie never truly
took responsibility for the things that
he did it was always somebody else's
fault you know the victim mentality only
ever goes so far and that's kind of what
Eddie hits on here and he basically
starts lashing out at his dad and then
basically says look I'm a screw-up yes I
get that like you did a lot of terrible
things to me but I'm finally at a point
where like I realized
like a lot of mistakes that I made I did
because like I was a functioning adult
and I refuse to accept my own past
I refuse to accept the responsibility
the decisions that I make then I just
chalked everything up to you but I'm
trying to be a good guy I'm trying to do
the right thing so here's what's gonna
happen pops like if at any point you
come along if at any point you know you
you basically appear in my life or the
life of this child the life of Dylan I
will kill you it's kind of giving him a
warning basically saying like don't ever
come back here again and so his response
is you're gonna wake up and you're gonna
be alone for the rest of your life which
is truly the one thing that Eddie
Brock's father really fears but in that
moment what is it happening as a simia
basically picks up Dylan they begin to
walk away and the city it says like both
of you guys are better off without me
basically telling us that like the
symbiote has left Eddie Brock that the
symbiote is going forward as his own
entity doing his own thing outside of
Eddie or anybody else which is something
that we haven't really seen before we've
seen that in so far as the symbiote like
seeks out a host and it might do some
things in between the time when it's
finding hosts but for the most part like
it seems to be out doing its own thing
now absent anybody else so it's kind of
cool it basically leaves it on like a
pretty huge cliffhanger like where the
heck did it go how is all this coming
together now so again really Donnie
Cates kind of splitting the difference
between the two focusing one part on the
symbiote and then focusing one part on
Eddie Brock and building both characters
respectively which i think is pretty
awesome because what do would mean is
that when Eddie rebonds to the to the
venoms Timmy at which he most likely
will do it basically gives us a chance
to kind of see them bond in a new light
and see the kind of like where they're
gonna go from there so I'm pretty
excited about it though with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]